el túnel carpiano es un paso estrecho en
la muñeca
está formado por huesos de la muñeca en
la parte inferior y a los lados y una
banda resistente de tejido conectivo
denominada ligamento carpiano transverso
en la parte superior
los tendones del músculo y el nervio
mediano pasan por el túnel carpiano
el nervio mediano controla los músculos
de la palma y de la base del pulgar lo
que permite que se muevan también
proporciona sensibilidad en el pulgar en
el dedo índice y medio
el síndrome del túnel carpiano es una
condición en la cual la inflamación del
tejido hace que se acumule presión
dentro del túnel carpiano esto presiona
al nervio mediano
con el tiempo la presión sobre el nervio
mediano produce síntomas en las áreas de
la mano que controla
síntomas comunes en estas áreas son
dolor entumecimiento hormigueo y
debilidad
los factores de riesgo para el síndrome
de túnel carpiano incluyen un túnel
carpiano más pequeño por ser mujer o por
genes que se transmiten de los padres
y lesiones en la muñeca
y otras afecciones médicas que causan
inflamación acumulación de fluido o daño
al nervio como la diabetes el embarazo
la artritis reumatoide la obesidad y el
hipotiroidismo
y movimientos repetitivos de la mano o
la muñeca
un tratamiento común para el síndrome de
túnel carpiano leve a moderado es
mantener la muñeca en una posición
neutral mediante el uso de una muñequera
o de una férula
además los fármacos antiinflamatorios no
esteroideos o los aine pueden ayudar a
aliviar el dolor
el médico también puede recomendar una
inyección de corticosteroides para
reducir la inflamación y la hinchazón
para síntomas moderados a graves el
médico puede recomendar un procedimiento
quirúrgico denominado liberación del
túnel carpiano este procedimiento se
puede realizar como un procedimiento
abierto a través de una incisión en la
palma de la mano y la muñeca o puede
hacerse como un procedimiento
endoscópico a través de una pequeña
incisión tipo ojo de cerradura el
cirujano realizará este procedimiento
con un endoscopio que es un dispositivo
que contiene una pequeña cámara e
instrumentos quirúrgicos en ambos
procedimientos el ligamento carpiano
transverso se cortará para aliviar la
presión sobre el nervio mediano
al final de los dos procedimientos la
incisión se cierra con suturas